[Applause]
happy friday everyone oh man do we have
a great show
janis dean is back
[Applause]
let's go to the president of her fan
club for comment
i see you
i appreciate you
and i thank you
we thank you too
what a shame
impaled on his own giant q-tip
i don't even think i read that correctly
i'm sure he'll land on his feet or his
ass i'm sure someone will lend him a
helping hand after he lent a groping one
to so many
but now he has time to hang out with
matt lauer and charlie rose
but be careful when you hang out with
charlie rose he really wants to hang out
in case you forgot
he would never close his robe
so guess what it's time for
everything is racist
so true so tonight a tale of two coasts
and two elections
as you know there's a recall going on in
california except this recall isn't for
defective air bags it's for a defective
wind bag namely his royal haircut gavin
newsom and it appears the person who has
the biggest chance of winning is larry
elder oh look he's black
but what's the la times claiming is
causing the recall racism
so do i have this right
a privileged white male governor who's
as ethnic as cauliflower pizza crust
is being recalled and his possible
replacement is a black man
yeah that sounds about as racist as an
episode of what's
happening here's a tip for the times it
might be faster if you just published a
list of things that aren't racist
so the reason for the recall isn't
rampant crime untreated mental illness
or homelessness or even the kardashians
it's not that californians can't get
water or go outside it's not high taxes
or legalized larceny it's racism
yes they claim that it's white supremacy
that's led to the recall in california
one of the most liberal states in the
nation
next they'll blame all these forest
fires on burning crosses
see their logic is that it's the racists
who are painting california as a hotbed
of crime and homelessness and those
things actually aren't real just
propaganda for some amorphous band of
bigots makes me wonder if the people who
write for the la times have ever been to
california have they have they been
downtown near the overpasses or walked
the beaches it's not white supremacists
sleeping on the benches building tent
cities littering the boardwalks with
syringes the elites would know this if
they ever stepped outside of their gated
communities in walled mansions and saw
how real people suffer from the policies
they promote
and really white supremacists are as
rare in california as celebrities who
bathe
but damn if only there was a way to
refute that claim
you know what
what if the leading republican
challenger was black
now that's too crazy no one would
believe that
but there it is that guy is larry elder
the black man who earlier had been
called the black face of white supremacy
by another columnist if that's true he's
been in blackface for almost 70 years
that's that kind of commitment would
make rachel dolezal jealous
now if you said those things about a
democrat candidate who happened to be
black you'd be canceled faster than a
cosby show reboot
now they're making the argument that
larry elder isn't really black because
for democrats blacks are great until you
challenge the democrats then it's about
the content of your character and to
them you only have character if you stay
on their plantation meanwhile on the
other side of the country there's
another election and maybe some hope for
cleaning up new york city right now the
city is experiencing its own renaissance
of recklessness i never thought i'd see
the day when a crazed man attacks a car
with a spatula
but that indeed happened here in the
city so first we're getting carjacked
now we're getting flapjacked
i don't know if i should call the cops
or ihop
the dude was later subdued and beaten by
a mob but this is what happens when da's
start waffling
oh
that even made me sick
anyway curtis sliwa is running for mayor
and he seems to actually give a damn
about the people living on its streets
and not the streets whose residents head
to the hamptons at the first sign of
trouble
this video made the rounds and it's
worth showing hey pelosi and friends
watch and learn tolerance
it's a perfect example yo what's up man
what's your name
how long do you live
six
would you rather be somewhere else penn
station
it's okay it's okay it's okay
it's all right it's all right
we'll take care of you okay
i just don't want to take advantage of
you guys you're not taking advantage
this is our responsibility
i'm running for mayor i'm gonna make
sure that you
and your other friends out here taken
care of okay
that's pretty moving stuff
and ignore the lefties screaming it was
staged as if aoc's whole life isn't one
big photo op
but that's what's really missing from
the left compassion along with logic
reason and truth the left pretends that
their policies help those less fortunate
but a stroll down the street in a major
blue city proves otherwise we see the
consequences and most of them are asking
you if you could spare any change
sticking a gun in your face or showing
you their junk and those are just the
democratic mayors
people like that disturbed man suffer on
the sidewalks of new york l.a atlanta
san fran seattle and anywhere else where
there's been no opposition to the rise
of the hard left
fact is when you look at the damage
being done you're seeing the
consequences of one party rule
there are many fifedems not a republican
in sight and that's what happens when
you have no competition ruin and real
sensible democrats should be pissed off
because without loyal opposition their
party degrades into a motley bunch of
woke brain-dead malicious zombies it's
not like the republicans are saviors by
any means you just need at least two
parties to keep each other from
destroying themselves
it's time we did something to turn the
tide but it's gonna it's gonna take more
than one guardian angel to defeat a
bunch of marxist devils and save those
two states it's gonna take a rebirth of
republicanism
too bad they're all moving to texas
[Applause]
today's forecast she's kicking some ass
fox news senior meteorologist judith
dean
he's had more roles than brian stelter
on thanksgiving author of the new book
the respondent
actor greg ellis
he's like your favorite sweater soft
warm and riddled with mops
fox news contributor cat tip
and finally
his style of comedy is no laughing
matter
writer comedian joe maggie
all right i'm gonna go to the only
person here that is still living in
california greg um
do you think larry elder is a sneaky
white supremacist
so let me get this straight the the the
white man is saying that the black man
is the black face of white supremacy yes
yes okay uh the guy from compton yes
yeah i mean having lived in look it's
like it's like gavin's been drinking the
woca cola yeah for too long right yeah i
mean i'm i'm against i want this recall
to happen you know whoever else comes in
i don't particularly care i don't want
him in yeah he has decimated california
and it's like this you know what we've
seen with companies you know we're
living in this era
where
won't capitalism
where where companies sell products to
to to to people who pretend to hate um
social justice uh and it's like
communism conflated with the capitalism
and and and gavin um look he's a pretty
fellow he's a good-looking chap yeah um
but he's not doing very well his whole
like i mean larry looks like you know
he'd really mix it up so yeah why not
yeah you'll lower your shot i've noticed
that the better
yeah
the better gavin's hair looks the worse
the state gets it's like it's like the
remember a picture of dorian gray
that wasn't that a movie or a book or
did i dream that it was a book yes all
right well that's the point i'm trying
to make like
his hair stays the same but the country
that state degrades just like the
picture in the attic janice the picture
in the attic or am i getting that is
that the dorian gray yes there was a
picture in the attic what's wrong with
you janice
i think they're just they're grasping at
straws now it's it's but there's no more
straws there is no more straws how about
he's just a terrible governor yes i
think they need like a meteorologist
who's really mad in california
well i was going to ask you i don't know
if curtis leewa has a chance for mayor
but you know you've been a you've been a
meteorologist for a long time
isn't it time you enter the political
realm and run for mayor
come on uh
would you vote for me
who wouldn't vote for you hell andrew
cuomo would vote for you i don't think
about it i don't think so um you know i
will say i heard that uh de bill de
blasio was thinking about running for
governor today
i mean we are in trouble we're in
trouble here in new york city but i will
let you know if that ever happens if the
winds change i'll help write your
speeches
then i'm gonna win there you go there
you go that's exactly the kind of answer
that makes you a perfect politician kiss
my butt
all right
not literally i don't want to get in
trouble with hr
joe good to see you stop by the foot
locker oh thanks craig
or is that old navy i'm not sure i i
don't know the brand i don't uh i don't
pay attention to labels unlike the
democrats in california because
i find i find personally you you attach
a label to something and then people
will stop thinking and and buy crap
that's what nike's proved yes and i
think that's what happened that's what
what's happening here in california what
they're saying doesn't make any sense i
mean gavin newsom had an otter as a pet
when he was a kid really yeah and like
i'll tell you what
most white people didn't have otters as
a pet growing up yes
i didn't have any pet i had to pretend
the straight cats love me
[Laughter]
much like much like cat owners pretend
that's true
by the way otters are actually more
appealing than cats right now you're
gonna make me upset
i was just that was just a friendly joke
cat i love cats well i saw it as
violence you know fun fact before i come
to you cat speaking of cats how many
cats does curtis sliwa have 17 right 17
cats and he lives in a studio apartment
400 square feet with 17 cats i learned
that because he was on the show so i
love this guy but that's creepy
crazy and i didn't mean crazy
i'm a doc yes you know i am a doctor uh
neurologist
cat
at least that's what i say in my van yep
so what are your thoughts about about
how it's not lack of water it's not a
lack of power it's not mental illness
it's great white racism that's at the
root of these problems yeah i just i
looked at that article and evaluated it
as if it were a research paper which now
after that dorian gray thing this makes
twice i will have used my english degree
[Laughter]
probably the only the only two times yes
uh it just doesn't add up obviously
there's no evidence to back that
conclusion because really most of the
articles says okay people are upset
about the rampant homelessness and a lot
of people that are homeless or people of
color therefore you're racist it's like
wait so if you don't want people of
color to be homeless that's racist yeah
that is actually backwards but that's
what happens when you stop thinking
mm-hmm he has gavin the governor has not
talked not talked to anybody that he has
been harmed he doesn't know
anything about the homeless or the drug
addicted or the mentally ill i'm not
even sure he knew some
that was a long way for probably the
worst joke ever ever made hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else